the las vegas filipino american festival
the sponsors of this next segment will
showcase filipino talents food and
beauty here to tell us more is michael
and judith bolda welcome to the show
thank you very much we're excited so
it's all happening this weekend craig
ranch park what can we expect out there
uh karaoke filipino pastime
fire dancers hot air balloon rides
um
beauty parade flowers of may
let's let's unpack this there's a lot
going on this weekend how much are
tickets first off uh seven dollars in
advance online ten dollars at the show
you can't beat that for the amount of
entertainment you're gonna get out this
weekend you mentioned that it's a
three-day karaoke contest yes what does
the winner of this contest get five
hundred dollars whoa
everyone's got a karaoke song right head
on out there for that hot air balloon
rice how does that work is the up down
kind of rides up and down they're
tethered but they go it's about a 30
minute ride they hover you can see the
town from above a beautiful view out
there too at craig ranch park and the
weather this weekend is going to be
spectacular for this
there's a battle of the bands going on
it is you have eight you have seven
bands competing for 500 hours again and
whose are there fans are we the judges
of who's judging the battle of the bands
the organics okay
uh there's a carnival every night
with fire dancers yeah tell me about
these fire dancers
these are more uh performers from the
edc edc
environment
they they swing orbs they have batons
with fire ends uh nobody's blowing fire
or um well they do that but for
insurance reasons i chose george exactly
there's four of them they're going to
open with our bands it's going to be
pretty spectacular the all filipino car
show tell me more this that intrigues me
um
i don't know if we're going to have that
there's some logistics issues okay there
are cars in the park there's a lot going
on right this is i had jollibee for the
first time this past year oh my god this
is the best chicken i've ever tasted so
the mascot is going to debut at the
festival this weekend first time in las
vegas wow what what is the jollibee
mascot
donch
what is that he's he's gonna die oh he's
gonna dance yeah is it a big giant bee
jolly b what is he's a big giant baby
yeah and he and he shakes it up and the
kids
it's a pied piper and this is something
this this is this is an event for the
entire family this weekend is it not it
is
yeah it's it's um from ant from young to
the jolly bee to the carnival
to middle age karaoke well karaoke
everybody sings in philippines everyone
so everyone's got a karaoke song
and we have all the songs you want to
sing on our board and then there's hot
air balloon rides there's battle of the
bands for they're young kids they're
getting exposure
they're good though the last thing i
want to ask real fast is about there's a
fashion show as well taking place
the uh the uh santa cruz the yeah
okay yeah so we have a paradigm that
actually they are we just want to be a
part of the filipino culture so they are
there is two years old oh my gosh that's
adorable yeah and
uh drizz up you know they're wearing
those
beautiful gum or maybe filipina gown you
know so there are some uh two three four
seven years old eight years old they're
so cute it's just adorable just
describing it it's gonna be a great
weekend thank you so much for joining us
and telling us more about it we
appreciate it so the las vegas filipino
american festival is friday through
sunday at craig ranch park for more
information or get those cheaper tickets
in advance go to las vegas filipino
american festival
jillian